empty all over again
inside ponte preeth market in the welsh
valleys
mary and her husband are shutting up
their stall
as the fire break begins absolutely
devastated
october november are my best trading
months of the year
in my business two weeks are taken for
me
we've started building the business back
up from the last lockdown
and now i feel as if we're taking two
steps forward and six steps back
a lot of people come to the market to
socialize with people
because they got no one else it's quite
devastating
up the road at the patriot regulars made
the most of last orders
the landlord says this lockdown alone
will cost him 16 grand
and he's worried whether christmas will
even happen
christmas is a busy time for us and he
can't get as many people in as we like
to get in here
and you know it's the thing is
it's you know it's earth in our industry
big time there's a lot of pubs in town
here and you're gonna have a lot of
problems which you're gonna close
i'm not gonna get through this pandemic
[Applause]
just like in march pubs gyms
hairdressers and restaurants
are all closed even supermarkets have
had to literally seal off
non-essential items all in a bid to
protect wells is hospitals
from becoming overwhelmed much of wales
including ponte preith was already under
some form of local
lockdown restriction for the next 16
days the whole of wales has to follow
the same set of rules what comes after
the fire break is still being worked out
the welsh government says a new national
set of guidelines will be issued from
november the 9th
but for those heading home there's a
feeling this won't be the last time
they're told to stay indoors i hope it
doesn't last until christmas because
obviously people like to go to other
households and things like that for
christmas time but um
if it has to off and it all swapped and
really done it i think it's gonna be
more than two weeks
and how does that make you feel crap
loss
lose work you know you lose everything
like
even if it does last two weeks i don't
think it's gonna be enough it'll just be
like a little blip we'd all think oh
it's gone now and come closer to
christmas here we go again
the first minister says this lockdown is
about saving lives
not christmas it'll be some weeks before
we know how successful
that has been damn whitehead sky news
in ponte preeth